milliardenspritze für konsum und
wirtschaft bundestag und bundesrat
bringen das konjunkturpaket auf den weg
erschütterndem ermittlungen im
missbrauchsskandal von bergisch gladbach
gibt es jetzt 30 1000 verdächtige und
tests am menschen die entwicklung eines
corona impfstoffs geht in die heiße
phase
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wir
auch norbert lehmann für den sport ein
tor von mir einen wumms nannte es
finanzminister scholz als er anfang des
monats das konjunkturpaket gegen die
korona krise vorstellte es soll
arbeitsplätze retten und wirtschaft und
konsum wieder in gang bringen und zwar
ab übermorgen deswegen stimmten im
eilverfahren innerhalb eines tages
bundestag und bundesrat zu dazu gleich
mehr
zunächst ein schneller blick darauf was
eigentlich drin steckt im sogenannten
roms das konjunkturpaket hat ein volumen
von 130 milliarden euro
einige punkte davon alle profitieren
sollen ist die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer von 19 auf 16 prozent bzw
von sieben auf fünf und die senkung der
umlage für umweltfreundlichen strom
familien erhalten im herbst einen
einmaligen kinderbonus von 300 euro pro
kind für alleinerziehende verdoppelt
sich der freibetrag für kinder in diesem
und im nächsten jahr auch kommunen
bekommen hilfe sie erhalten die hälfte
der ausfallenden gewerbesteuern und bund
und länder unterstützen die kommunen bei
einem teil der sozial leistungskosten
für bedürftige 50 der 130 milliarden
euro fließen in ein sogenanntes
zukunftspaket damit will der bund unter
anderem die digitalisierung
beschleunigen und etwa mit e-autos den
klimaschutz fördern
dieses milliarden paket muss deutschland
komplett über neue schulden finanzieren
es ist das wert stellt die
bundesregierung damit die richtigen
weichen und wer profitiert wirklich
davon
alles fragen die heute im parlament noch
mal diskutiert wurden weniger fasst
zusammen
olaf scholz muss noch seinen richtigen
platz finden und dann bleibt ihm nur
zuzuhören wie die opposition das
konjunkturpaket auseinandernimmt keine
soli abschaffen keine dauerhafte
ertragssteuer senken keine
steuervereinfachung keine bürokratie
erleuchtung einfach nichts was einer
zwangs kollabierten volkswirtschaft
wieder auf die beine helfen könnte am
meisten pflegt der koalition ihre
mehrwertsteuersenkung um die ohren
falsches instrument sagte opposition
fraglich ob das geld beim verbraucher
ankommen meine befürchtung ist die
profiteure dieses gesetzes werden
diejenigen sein die in der krise gerade
nicht gelitten haben beispielsweise die
online versandhändler meine damen und
herren glauben sie im ernst dass irgend
jemand der gerade um seinen arbeitsplatz
oder seine soziale existenz fürchtet im
moment keine anderen sorgen hat als sich
ein auto oder eine neue küche zu kaufen
das sie jetzt davon reden dass das
nichts bringen würde
deutet einiges darauf hin sie wollen
überhaupt keine entlastung der mittleren
einkommen sie wollen ausschließlich
belastungen gehören
einkommen geben die man auf ihre
scheuklappen bilder haben ideologe afd
und fdp lehnen das paket ab linke und
grüne enthalten sich so unkalkulierbar
seien die folge ob wie und wem dieses
herzstück wirklich helfen wird sie
wissen es nicht
ob es wirklich die nachfrage ankurbeln
wird sie wissen es nicht jetzt das
richtige zu tun ist etwas für die
nächste generation jetzt nichts zu tun
hat einfach
sie hinterlassen einen scherbenhaufen
das wollen wir nicht im schnellverfahren
haben bundestag und bundesrat über das
paket abgestimmt ab übermorgen gilt auch
die eu will schulden aufnehmen um
betroffenen mitgliedstaaten zu helfen
gestritten wird über einen 750
milliarden euro programm
deutschland und frankreich hatten das
ganze angestoßen
heute empfing die kanzlerin im
französischen präsidenten auf schloss
meseberg es ist ihr erstes treffen mit
einem ausländischen staatschef seitdem
corona ausbruch über morgen übernimmt
deutschland die eu ratspräsidentschaft
äußerlich herrliches ambiente inhaltlich
die größte krise der eu stark unter der
banerjee lässt sich schon ein fazit
dieses besuchs ziehen ja angela merkel
und immer nur im makro sind gerade dabei
dieses fazit zu ziehen die
pressekonferenz läuft noch aber die
ersten minuten haben wir schon hören
können die beiden haben hier eine gute
zwei stunden zusammengesessen
auf schloss meseberg und wir sind mit
einer klaren mit einer klaren nachricht
sozusagen rausgekommen nämlich die achse
deutschland frankreich steht und zwar in
zweierlei hinsicht einmal kurzfristig
wenn es um die nächsten maßnahmen geht
die die eu beraten will beim kommenden
eu-gipfel
das sind der haushalt für die jahre 20
21 bis 27 und das große
konjunkturprogramm mit dem die eu
gemeinsam aus der pandemie aus der krise
und der wirtschaftskrise die durch die
korona krise ausgelöst worden es
herauskommen will
da haben sowohl magna als auch merkel
hier noch einmal ganz deutlich gesagt
sie stehen zu dem vorschlag den sie
gemacht haben 500 milliarden euro für
die am schlimmsten betroffenen regionen
als zuschüsse
da lassen sie sich nicht
auseinanderdividieren und wollen auch
gemeinsam in die verhandlung
hingehen und der zweite punkt ist ein
längerfristiger wenn es um die zukunft
der eu geht in diesem jahr hat
deutschland die ratspräsidentschaft im
nächsten jahr ist dann auch frankreich
an der reihe
und beide wollen also gemeinsam in
richtung klima erreichung der klimaziele
arbeiten digitalisierung ist ein großes
programm man möchte also einen großen
bogen ziehen und zeigen gemeinsam stehen
deutschland und frankreich für gleiche
ziele dankeschön für diese
brandaktuellen informationen vom schloss
meseberg statt unterlag und ella
banerjee war das innenpolitisch steht
der französische präsident massiv unter
druck bei den kommunalwahlen gestern
wurden die kandidaten seines bündnisses
in vielen städten abgestraft erfolge
feierten vor allem die grünen und ihnen
nahe stehenden kandidaten in großen
städten wie straßburg lyon oder bordeaux
am vormittag kündigte metro an in den
kommenden zwei jahren 15 milliarden euro
in den ökologischen wandel zu industrie
wegweisende und spannende tage sind es
in polen bei der präsidentenwahl gestern
hat der national konservative
amtsinhaber die absolute mehrheit
verpasst jetzt muss er in zwei wochen in
die stichwahl gegen den warschauer
oberbürgermeisters kowski wer will ein
liberales und europa freundliches polen
und könnte im fall seiner wahl
umstrittenen regierungsvorhaben stoppen
aus warschau natalie steger noch in der
nacht steigen die kontrahenten wieder in
den wahlkampf ein
es geht um jede stimme amtsinhaber duda
und sein liberaler kontrahent kowski sie
müssen für die stichwahl neue wähler
dazu gewinnen
der präsident wird jetzt offen und die
stimmen der rechtsextremen partei polens
und setzt außerdem weiter auf soziale
versprechen
ich werde dafür sorgen dass die
vierzehnte rente ausgezahlt wird wie der
premierminister es versprochen hat wir
halten sein wird
regierung und präsident gehen im
gleichschritt seit jahren die pis hat
die absolute mehrheit im parlament und
will auf den präsidentenpalast mal genau
das will der oppositionskandidat der
warschauer bürgermeister just copski
durchbrechen
er wirbt für mehr toleranz und will
konflikte mit der eu vermeiden was uns
weh tut ist das totale monopol dieser
macht die alle institutionen und
kontrollinstanzen politisiert hat ich
denke dass kowski das größere potenzial
hat sich eine breitere wähler basis
aufzubauen
das heißt aber nicht dass du da
stagnieren wird aber da hat sich die
türen ein bisschen verschlossen wenn es
um die wähler der mitte geht nach seinen
gut 40% gestern ist du da der favorit
doch just kowski hat in den letzten
wochen gezeigt er kann aufholen
dudas sieg ist noch nicht in trockenen
tüchern
zurück nach deutschland zu einem
verbrechen das nicht nur wegen seiner
dimension die ermittler an ihre grenzen
bringt ihm sei übel geworden sagte nrw
justizminister heute im missbrauchsfall
von bergisch gladbach werden spuren
verfolgt die zu gut 30.000 verdächtigen
führen könnten
sie sollen die kinder sexuell
missbraucht und sich dabei im netz
gegenseitig ermuntert und betäubungs
tipps gegeben haben
rote farbe 120 beamte täglich sind noch
immer im einsatz allein für den
missbrauchs komplex bergisch gladbach
sie ermitteln und sie finden
alleine bei den ermittlungen sind über
30.000 spuren gefunden worden
menschen die sich im dark knight oder
auch im ganz normalen netz miteinander
darüber unterhalten wie sie kinder
vergewaltigen können wie sie kinder
beruhigen können um sie zu missbrauchen
die ermittler sollen nun durch eine
spezielle task force bei der
staatsanwaltschaft unterstützt werde
denn die auswertung der beweismittel ist
oft schwierig es geht um digitale spuren
die werden wir jetzt im rahmen der
ermittlungsarbeit einzelnen personen
zuordnen müssen das heißt die aufgabe
besteht darin aus einer digitalen spur
das kann ip-adresse sein
das kann einen decknamen in einem forum
sein oder dergleichen diese zuzuordnen
konkreten straftaten und diese dann auch
zuzuordnen wenn möglich konkreten
tatverdächtigen sie lesen in gruppen
chats wie sich täter zum missbrauch
verabreden wie zögernde von anderen im
chat zur tat gedrängt werden und sie
stoßen auf immer mehr nur bitter wie das
ist wir drücken immer wieder in dem
komplex auf neue tat vor der schier und
auch neue geschädigte kinder wir sind
jetzt über etwa sieben monate dran
ein ende ist aus meiner sicht im moment
nicht absehbar
das erste urteil im riesigen missbrauchs
komplex viele mai
der mann wurde zu zehn jahren haft
verurteilt unterbringung auf unbestimmte
zeit in der psychiatrie verfügt anfang
august soll der nächste prozess beginnen
kommen wir zu den aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland da waren die
täglichen neuinfektionen ja angestiegen
wegen einiger lokaler ausbrüche wie dem
in der fleischfabrik tönnies im kreis
gütersloh jetzt allerdings gehen die
bundesweiten zahlen wieder zurück im
durchschnitt der vergangenen woche haben
sich jeden tag 490 menschen neu mit dem
virus angesteckt dabei gab es ihm gut
140 kreisen in deutschland in den
vergangenen sieben tagen überhaupt keine
neue infektion sagt das
robert-koch-institut nur im kreis
gütersloh lag die zahl der
neuinfektionen über der kritischen
grenze von 50 heute gab
ministerpräsident laschet bekannt das
öffentliche leben dort bleibt für eine
weitere woche eingeschränkt die
beschränkungen im nachbar kreis
warendorf dagegen laufen morgen wirklich
beenden kann die pandemie nur ein
wirksamer impfstoff die spritze gegen
korona darauf wartet die welt forscher
aus vielen verschiedenen ländern liefern
sich deshalb ein beispielloses
wettrennen mehr als 130 corona impfstoff
projekte gibt es weltweit
mit dabei auch die deutschen unternehmen
bieren tech und fuhr weg
offen bereits klinische studien mehr
dazu hat jetzt eva schiller ein pieks
der leben retten könnte in der uniklinik
tübingen wird der korona impfstoff eines
deutschen herstellers klinisch getestet
über 1000 bewerbungen gab es für die
studienteilnahme kerngesund und unter 60
nach diesen kriterien wurde biologin
stefanie dietz ausgewählt so schnell
ging es noch nie weltweit werden bereits
über zehn corona impfstoffe am menschen
getestet
in deutschland sind die produkte der
hersteller biontech und fuhr weg
erst in der anfangsphase der prüfung mit
wenigen probanden
es sind maximal 168 vorgesehen in dieser
ersten phase
und dies sind eingeteilt in wesentlichen
drei gruppen die unterschiedliche
dosierungen erhalten nämlich zwei
mikrogramm 4 mikrogramm und acht
mikrogramm wenn alles gut funktioniert
und keine sicherheits oder
verträglichkeits probleme auftreten
nach der ersten phase bei der es um die
verträglichkeit geht beginnt phase 2 in
der auch dosierung und reaktion des
immunsystems geprüft werden
dann folgen massen testungen auf die
zuverlässigkeit des schutzes
voraussichtlich im ausland es ist schon
jetzt so dass auch die deutschen firmen
kooperation weltweit suchen und
klinische prüfung zur wirksamkeit
eventuell in china oder in südamerika
durchführen werden weil dort die
infektionsraten entsprechend hoch sind
bis anfang nächsten jahres dürften sich
mehrere impfstoffe weltweit durchsetzen
um dann schnellstmöglich milliarden
impfdosen herstellen zu können
produzieren die firmen schon jetzt in
der hoffnung dass ihr impfstoff das
rennen gegen die zeit gewinnt auch wenn
die reisebeschränkungen nach und nach
gelockert werden gilt in vielen ländern
noch immer wer keinen negativen corona
test zeigen kann muss erst mal in
quarantäne
der frankfurter flughafen bietet jetzt
reisenden ein
testcenter an allerdings nicht umsonst
der standard test kostet knapp 60 euro
das ergebnis gibt es nach wenigen
stunden wer es schneller möchte muss
tiefer in die tasche greifen
viele denken in diesen tagen an urlaub
die bundesländer aber planen die zeit
nach dem schulferien zdf heute hat bei
allen ländern nachgefragt wie die
schulen für den herbst und auf eine
mögliche zweite welle vorbereitet sind
die antworten finden sie in unserer wie
schwierig es ist die korona pandemie in
den griff zu bekommen zeigt der blick
nach südkorea
das land gilt als musterland im kampf
gegen die krankheit und hatte den
ausbruch schnell eingedämmt und zwar
ohne ausgangssperre
aber mit abstandsregeln und vielen tests
und infektionsketten wurden konsequent
nachverfolgt doch jetzt rollt eine
zweite welle an leicht aber
kontinuierlich steigt die zahl der
infizierten auf mittlerweile fast 13.000
stefanie schöner baum berichtet die
angst ist wieder da auf den straßen in
soul und im rest des landes
die infektionszahlen steigen wieder die
unbekümmertheit des warmen sommers passt
nicht mehr zu der stimmung in südkorea
wir müssen wieder aufpassen
es gibt noch kein impfmittel wir müssen
aufpassen aber wir können deswegen jetzt
auch nicht auf einmal keine freunde mehr
sehen
also treffen wir uns kurz zumindest wir
treffen uns und erledigen dinge nur
gemeinsam
heute gehen wir zusammen zum friseur
bisher galt südkorea als vorzeigeland
durch massives testen und handy tracking
konnte die erste corona welle eingedämmt
werden
monti ist virologin und gegen einen
harten lockdown ganzer stadtteile
doch die bevölkerung muss mitmachen wenn
die zahl der neuerkrankungen mit dieser
geschwindigkeit weiter zunimmt wäre die
belastung für die krankenhäuser zu groß
daher versuchen wir die bedingungen für
die aufhebung der quarantäne zu ändern
die garantien könnten verlängert werden
die nachtclubs länger geschlossen
bleiben
das wichtigste signal an die bevölkerung
ist aber haltet abstand ganz anderes
thema jetzt warum erschießt ein junger
mann seine eltern seine beiden
halbgeschwister onkel und tante so
geschehen im januar in rot am see in
baden württemberg aus rache sagte der 27
jährige heute zum prozessauftakt und
legte ein umfassendes geständnis ab
seine mutter habe ihn misshandelt und
vergiften wollen ob der mann voll
schuldfähig ist ist noch unklar
ein urteil wird ende nächster woche
erwartet und noch kurz der blick über
die grenze nach frankreich ins elsass
dort hat die endgültige abschaltung des
ältesten atomkraftwerks des landes
begonnen
rund 43 jahre war das akw fessenheim am
netz proteste dagegen gab es in
deutschland und der schweiz wegen
häufiger störfälle und das
erdbebenrisiko in der region und damit
sie zum sport norbert und heiklen
fußballfreunden in corona zeiten ja
allerdings sei es in liverpool oder
hierzulande in bremen und bielefeld
tausende fans feierten öffentlich ihre
mannschaften ja und missachteten dabei
die korona regeln konsequenzen für den
spielbetrieb hat das bislang nicht
in bielefeld jubelten hunderte fans mit
ihren spielern nach dem aufstieg in
bremen wurde der relegationsplatz in
kleineren gruppen auf den straßen
gefeiert und in liverpool war die
begeisterung über den ersten
meistertitel nach 30 jahren so groß dass
selbst der meistertrainer
in einem offenen brief mahnte eure
leidenschaft ist meine leidenschaft aber
das wichtigste ist jetzt dass wir auf
solche öffentlichen versammlungen
verzichten das sind wir den in unserer
gesellschaft schuldig die am meisten
gefährdet sind
tausende hatten den titel gefeiert der
fc liverpool will die große meisterparty
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt nachholen
sportlich auf talfahrt finanziell unter
druck
schalke 04 will offenbar als erster
bundesligist eine gehaltsobergrenze
einführen
mehr als 2,5 millionen euro sollen neu
verpflichtete schalke profis künftig
nicht verdienen die zweitschlechteste
mannschaft der rückrunde fanproteste in
einer menschenkette vor allem gegen den
aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden clemens
tönnies und verbindlichkeiten in höhe
von 197 millionen euro
der vorwurf vieler anhänger schalke
verkaufe die seele des vereins jetzt
denkt die vereinsführung laut
informationen der süddeutschen zeitung
über die einführung einer
gehaltsobergrenze für profis nach
demnach soll kein neuer spieler vertrag
2,5 millionen euro jahresgehalt
überschreiten
die reaktionen reichen von zustimmung
bis zu skepsis vergessen weil es
überhaupt nicht durchführbar ist das
führt uns nicht weiter ich das sind
alles scheinheilige diskussionen der
schalker vorstand um alexander jobst und
jochen schneider wollte sich heute nicht
äußern und verwies auf ein
mediengespräch am mittwoch das was von
mir eingestellte beim wetter gibt's eine
kurze verschnaufpause bevor neue
gewitter aufziehen mehr dazu hat gleich
ist intern um viertel vor zehn begrüßt
sie claus kleber im heute-journal hier
ist morgen christian sieh was dran
ich wünsche ihnen noch eine gute woche
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter im süden gibt es
hauptsächlich ruhiges wetter morgen aber
im norden an den küsten regnerisches und
windiges wetter ja und dann erreichte
uns dann morgen abend und in der nacht
ein neues tief und bringt noch mehr
regen und gewitter vor allem dann am
mittwoch schauen wir erstmal in die
kommende nacht und da gibt es an der
nordseeküste regen und viel wind aus
südwest teils stürmisch sonst ist es
sternenklar vor allem nach südosten hin
dass bei temperaturen von acht grad in
der eifel und 15 grad zum beispiel im
osten deutschlands morgen an den küsten
viele wolken vor allem an der nordsee
und auch weiter zu ost sehen
und dieser regen zieht langsam etwas
weiter ins binnenland aber wird uns
nicht überqueren
eine richtung osten da gibt es etwas
sonnenschein und ganz im westen einzelne
schauer noch mehr sonnenschein gibt es
dann zwischen oberrhein und richtung
bodensee
sonst aber auch trocken im süden
temperaturen dazu bis 26 grad an der
neiße und 18 grad an der nordsee am
mittwoch viel los schauer und gewitter
und kräftiger regen der von westen nach
osten zieht und das bei 30 grad die
nächsten tage mit schauern aber nicht
mehr ganz so heiß
ein schöner abend